while this world for British  intelligence is bestest information to  us scientists the American High Command  is very interested the rocket scientists  they was working on in Ukraine nuclear  fusion I have orders from High Command  the requisition your team for this  mission the Nazis have him he wanted  these men need you to run a little  errand for them he travels Poland  tonight we came here to do a job  let's get that job yes  I'm offering you a way out a chance of  freedom a chance at a real life I know  your country needs me working very  research every Germany the whole Paris  looking for you  20 miles across the enemy territory to  the pickup sit let's back up  Fabian is the key the end this war  sorry you ready  you  you